alright so I'd like to welcome you all
thank you for coming tonight thank you
also to Roger hertog for making all this
possible thank you also the Saltzman
Institute for co-sponsoring this lecture
series and the School of International
and public affairs for providing this
venue but thank you especially to Grand
Mallinson for coming tonight and talking
with us about his work to control the
spread of nuclear weapons as many of you
know he's been working on this subject
for many years now even before then he
was working on the problem of nuclear
weapons back when he wrote a classic
book called the essence of decision it's
a book that I think virtually everybody
who studied international affairs in the
second half of the 20th century would
have would have read it's really a
classic study not just for political
scientists for historians as well but of
course he did more than that he was the
founding dean of the Kennedy School of
Government one of the most influential
of Nod the most influential public
policy schools in the world he's the
director of the Belfer Center and in
recent years he's worked especially on
this problem of nuclear proliferation
you may many of you I'm sure I've seen
this book nuclear terrorism the ultimate
preventable catastrophe one of the most
influential books that have been
produced in this field but I have to say
it's because of the impact of Graham
Allison that some people don't worry
about this problem as much as they used
to I hope Bob dervis won't mind if I
mentioned something that he said in one
of these lectures just a few weeks ago
he said that he used to worry about the
problem of loose nukes in the former
Soviet Union but then Graham Allison had
a bunch of professors up at Harvard got
active about it and they got to be heard
in the halls of Congress and they got
things done in the nunn-lugar
legislation which as we all know is an
ongoing program that continues to this
day and at least according to Bob
service because of the work of Graham
Allison he doesn't worry about that as
much as he did but I think maybe it's
fitting then that we have Graham Allison
to come
here and speak with us night about why
we should continue to worry about this
problem now as before maybe now more
than ever so let me turn things over to
him thank you so thank you very much for
a very generous introduction and let me
say how pleased I am to be here I
actually just came but I was saying to
prank from Washington where I was today
talking with my colleague ash Carter
who's currently the Undersecretary of
defense for acquisition and gallucci and
I were talking to him about nuclear
attribution and accountability to great
new topics on the agenda for that the
looking at nuclear danger going forward
namely how do you find out whose
fingerprints on the making of the
material that would be a bomb that
exploded somewhere so that a seller of a
bomb or a user of a bomb won't imagine
that they could hide behind a cloak of
anonymity and then the more difficult
policy question which is what would
constitute accountability for some sense
of somebody would be held to account for
these purposes so there are lots and
lots of great topics that are open today
for students in a way that they had
pretty much been all worked over by the
latter stages of the Cold War post the
Cold War and in the new environment in
the nuclear arena there are lots of
questions to which the consumer which
the conceptual Arsenal hasn't caught up
so i would say great opportunities and i
commend your professors Franken Matt for
putting this effort together for most
people most places nuclear is a oh that
was a cold war the Cold War's over move
on unfortunately
the cold or have been the good news is
that kool lures over and we won in that
sense but the bad news is that all the
things that were made during the Cold
War most of them remain and in any case
you by now learnt the half-life of
uranium and plutonium so that's a long
long long time there's a problem that'll
be with us for some time and there are
lots of new questions to be addressed in
the domain of nuclear terrorism and
nuclear proliferation and indeed if you
look at the india-pakistan standoff even
god forbid nuclear Wars so I commend you
the Columbia and the professions for
putting together such a good program and
I'm happy to be part of it let me tell
you what I propose to do today so this
presentation will take about a half hour
it'll come in three parts first is a
quiz no no Harvard presentation is
complete without a quiz so you should
have got a copy of the quiz in the back
i'm going to give you about two minutes
in a minute to do the answers and then
you should be able to get the answers to
the questions or you should be able to
infer my answers before we're done
secondly i'm going to then show you
about three minutes of a video clip 01
is the first is the trailer to a new
movie that's going to premiere i think
here in New York next Friday called a
countdown to zero it's made by the
producer of inconvenient truth the Al
Gore movie who's trying to frame the
nuclear challenge and the movie does I
think a pretty good job of identifying
some aspects of nuclear danger and then
has I think a little bit less persuasive
conclusion but still it's a very
interesting movie I've had a chance to
screen it a couple of weeks ago and i
would say it it engages the ambition for
the
producer is that it should be as it
should have as much impact in helping
the general public get their mind around
nuclear danger as inconvenient truth did
for climate that's a very high ambition
okay the second is a little clip from a
another documentary that's just being
released by the nuclear threat
initiative which is an organization of
CM none Henry Kissinger George Shultz
and bill Perry are and the so-called
four horsemen and they produced a
documentary in which they are mainly are
offering their own best judgments about
nuclear danger so that one's also
available and I think it will be
released very shortly in any case it'll
be available at Indian or so the second
part of the presentation is three
minutes worth of that then third I'm
going to take you through some
PowerPoint slides fairly quickly that
highlight the arguments that are
presented in somewhat more detail in the
Foreign Affairs piece which is back
there which was in January Foreign
Affairs about the global nuclear order
some trimmed lines that I find to be
particularly disturbing then we'll stop
and do questions and discussion so
that's the plan if I were to summarize
today's presentation in a single
sentence it would be this question
number three could the global nuclear
order be as fragile today as the global
financial order was two years ago when
conventional wisdom declared it to be
sounds stable and resilient now if you
go back through that history I'd say the
beginning of wisdom on the topic of
systemic risk is humility so after the
financial crash many people came forward
to say well who could not see
subprime mortgages and who could not see
the huge leverage at Bear Stearns who
could not see him who could not see the
woods the answer is almost everybody
could not see okay almost everybody or
if if before last December you had heard
a presentation that said the euro is at
risk because the structure of the Euro
puts the heart before the horse namely
has a monetary union with no fiscal fed
or discipline and that's fatally flawed
and therefore it could come unraveled
prior to the grease events in December
that would have seemed extreme very
extreme in fact most people would have
said yes of course there's a structural
flaws but notice the market has up
valued the euro versus the dollar a
hundred percent over these nine years
but now after the fact if you look at
they you're at the at the Greek
situation and at the impact one the
whole question of the viability of the
euro and the value of the Euro
structural questions appear so modesty
with respect to systemic judgment
nonetheless my judgment my best judgment
on the answer to this question could the
global nuclear order be fragile is yes
and that's not an extreme view and it's
not a unique view so in the video you'll
see Henry Kissinger who has a same view
or I'm sure you've been dealing with
nuclear spring here President Obama as
same view that is he sees the global
nuclear order at risk and the sequence
of events that occurred this spring
starting with the Nuclear Posture review
and the Nuclear Security Summit and the
NPT review conference and the new start
are all about trying to bend
trend lines that are otherwise
undermining disorder so that's in one
sentence could they want to be at risk
let me then proceed as I suggested in
the three parts first as a quiz you get
two minutes okay done it's a quick quiz
only Tenten questions the answers are
either yes no or I gave you one multiple
choice
good
okay let me move us on to part two that
was part one well you'll get a chance to
come back around them and I think by the
time we're done you'll know my answers
to the questions which not necessarily
correct but they're my interest and and
then the questions and answers we'll
have time to discuss them so now we're
going to part two which is the videos
the first as I say the trailer from this
new movie from bender the inconvenient
truth guy called count down to zero
focused on acquiring in particular
all black market seniors well aware /
caught by luck a Russian naval base
a lie North Korea they are prepared to
start training nuclear weapons
technology in general are of paper mr.
broke till four living relatives you're
not addicted kill for weed people out in
front of the airplane to professionally
built the right space rush lions roaring
especially ones we told the Russian to
launch that rocket but somebody must go
about the password on the Russians
actually opened up the command control
cuantos the button put it on the desk
and said align your attacker fortunately
Yelton wasn't drunk and he didn't
believe the military was telling me
it doesn't take
all of the personal emotional words
could kill
defeatism of their country can I develop
Sunday strength among themselves hello
did nothing for the medication that I
would expect that the usual nuclear
Curtin thinks some time you kill you is
very buff so the trailer you can get off
of youtube and as I say I think the
movie premieres next weekend and the
documentary I would check out in DI org
and I don't know exactly when it's going
to be released
there we go good
thank you good
okay so ah how to think about a risk
that's low probability or uncertain
probability but catastrophic
consequences in the Cold War we came to
have a little look whatever maxim that
said risk equals probability x
consequences so if the consequences are
genuinely catastrophic a very low
probability of such an event makes it
something that has to be riveting and in
the case of the Cold War the fear was a
general nuclear war that in the case of
the Cuban Missile Crisis might have
killed a hundred million people in a
brief span and that at the height of the
Cold War might have succeeded in
actually erasing the US and the Soviet
Union from the map and in the case of
nuclear winter one of the possible
scenarios maybe even succeeding in
killing everybody so if the consequences
are so huge what's the difference
between a one percent chance of such a
consequence and a ten percent chance in
terms of what you should do and the
answer is not much as you should do
everything conceivable to avoid such
consequences now how likely is a nuclear
terrorists attacked that's I know one of
the topics shall be considering in the
course in in nuclear terrorism the book
that bat mentioned i offered my view
this is back in 2004 that on the current
trend lines the likelihood was greater
than even that is 50% plus within a
decade that I get you to the end of 2014
the commission that Congress
established as a successor to the 911
Commission called the Commission on WMD
terrorism and proliferation nine
Americans five Democrats four
Republicans chaired by Bob Graham and
Jim talent to former senators offered
its view and this was now in December of
2008 that again on the current trend
lines the likelihood of a nuclear or
biological terrorist successful
terrorist attack somewhere in the world
in the next five years that's by the end
of 13 is greater than even now you think
whoa how do we how does won't even try
to think about this how likely was 911
if you go back through all the arguments
that were made before nine eleven about
why something like that couldn't happen
only that never happened before so
that's a good reason for thinking good
that yeah or it would be too hard or go
down the list as condi rice testified to
the 911 Commission he said no one could
have imagined terrorists hijacking
airplanes and crashing them into
buildings and what was the principal
conclusion of the 911 Commission the
principal conclusion was that the u.s.
government suffered from a quote failure
of imagination because when you say
something is unimaginable or even
inconceivable note that's not a
statement about the world that's a
statement about your ability to conceive
or to a mansion so what I'm going to try
to do now is to get us to try to imagine
something that may seem far-fetched even
unimaginable namely an unraveling of
elements of the global nuclear order to
a conclusion that could mean a bomb
exploding devastating the heart of one
great city somewhere in the world or
indeed even a regional nuclear war and
the spread of nuclear weapons so that's
the year that's the plan so what's the
single greatest threat to US national
security short-term medium-term and
long-term I probably wouldn't put such a
bold step President Obama says
short-term medium-term and long-term I
don't think it's worth arguing for a
long time whether the rise of China
might be an equivalent threat over the
medium term of the long term but i would
say nuclear terrorism is a category one
threat well I remember a day yeah was
the director of the IAEA the
International Atomic Energy Agency
nuclear terrorism is the most serious
danger the world is facing so this is
not just an American point of view back
in 2005 Kofi Anan and panelled a group
called was a commission on 21st century
threats challenges and change were asked
to look at the next 25 years and
identify the most important challenges
globally they identified six challenges
of which one was climate disruption one
was global poverty one was pandemics
they gave pride a place to nuclear among
those nuclear danger and they say and
this is a very I think telling quote
we're approaching a point at which the
erosion of the non-proliferation regime
that's the NPT and the rest of the
associated elements of the order that
have held back the spread of nuclear
weapons is eroding to the point that it
could become irreversible after which
would be a cascade of proliferation and
I'll have more to say about that
okay what about these trend lines in the
Foreign Affairs piece I offer 10 trend
lines that are powerfully propelled
better I say and I think if you look at
the analysis of it eroding what has been
the stuff of the global nuclear order
one of these is the emergence of nuclear
black marketeers or what alberte called
the walmart of private-sector
proliferation now who was mr. AQ Khan he
was the father of the Pakistani nuclear
bomb Brooklyn so he's a hero in Pakistan
for having organized the effort that
built Pakistan's nuclear bomb how did he
do this well he worked originally at you
wrinkle uh he stoled our from you Rinko
the technology for making centrifuges he
then went to Pakistan and developed a
very effective network for buying things
in the black market and the gray market
for putting together a program and then
over a period of more than a decade he
built with a number of associates but he
is the recognized father the Pakistani
nuclear bomb and the Pakistani nuclear
arsenal at some stage since he had
learned how black markets worked in this
process because he needed to be in him
to dubai's it occurred to him that
perhaps he could do cells as well and
maybe why couldn't he keep a good part
of the money himself not still not
unraveled entirely how much who else in
pakistan knew about what was going on
but in fact he AQ Khan developed a very
effective impressive global sourcing a
network from which he would have pieces
for the centrifuges made in malaysia he
ran his money out of Switzerland he ran
some of the some of the transfer of
materials in Dubai he got a number of
pieces of equipment from Europe
so he had a global sourcing process and
who who were buyers well North Korea a
lot of stuff was traded Iran he visited
often Libya is the case that we know
best because after 2003 when the Libyans
were caught Qaddafi he decided to
confess and basically to invite the US
and the British in to see what he had
bought and what he was doing and the
reason why this material is very well
understood is that it is now in Oak
Ridge Tennessee so American intelligence
agents and British intelligence agents
went collected all this stuff went
through the track record of how and
where it had come from in otherwise here
on the Left errs you have six containers
uf6 is starter fuel for a nuclear bomb
so you take this uf6 the amount that
he's got there you run them through the
centrifuges and you'll have enough for
your first nuclear bomb the middle
middle box is the centrifuges these are
the devices that enrich uranium starting
with uf6 and then third very interesting
here is a nuclear warhead design which
is not a crude nuclear bomb not a crude
nuclear bomb this is a design for a very
advanced nuclear bomb that Pakistan had
got from China which then AQ Khan
privately sold and this designed for a
bomb then appeared in a one on a
computer which then was captured in
Europe but if it was on a computer who
knows to whom other addresses it was
sent North Korea another trimline
undermining the global nuclear order is
the fact that one of the poorest weakest
smallest most isolated states on earth
has successfully violated the rules of
regime and the direct demands from the
gamekeepers namely the u.s. so-called
sole superpower and China their neighbor
and has proceeded methodically to
produce what's now 10 bombs worth of
plutonium and conduct to nuclear weapons
tests so here's mr. Kim jong-il a very
strange character a person who's I think
demonstrated a capacity for risk-taking
and for our boldness that really is
breathtaking breathnach so what has he
done he's taken North Korea this young
bong reactor produced after from the
spent fuel 10 bombs worth of plutonium
conducted two nuclear tests has
developed a fairly impressive missile
program and of course this is only for
his own parcel and with this he would
not do anything else that would be
dangerous you might hope but you'll be
wrong for many many years North Korea
was known as quote missiles or us you've
got money we got missiles they've
delivered missiles actually as late as
2006 to Lorraine but who could imagine
that North Korea would think that it
could sell to Syria a young bond style
reactor get paid for it and get away
with it if I had made that as a
hypothetical prior to the event I think
you would have said though that's just
much much much too far-fetched I didn't
believe he would do that okay it's just
too big too visible sir excuse me this
is right next door to Israel
and right next door to a rock we're
we're operating in any case without
question Kim Jong Il Sole to Syria this
young buck style reactor which was there
and about to start operating until it
was bombed by Israel and therefore
eliminated but from Kim Jong Il's point
of view so what about this I made a sale
I got paid the Syrians took the
consequences at least now people know
I'm in business and what else happened
to North Korea within six months the US
was back at the six-party talks talking
to him you really I know that and of
course you've dealt with Iran and yet
not see I ran all over the newspapers
including this latest most interesting
episode with the defector double agent
Reed effector spy whoever and whatever
he was but in any case you know about
mr. Ahmadinejad so he's got this
facility at Natanz where he produces uf6
sorry he's fahan he then brings it to
Natanz which is his enrichment facility
at the enrichment facility since 2006
Iran has produced now more than 4,500
pounds of low-enriched uranium which is
more than enough after further
enrichment for their first two nuclear
bombs has mastered the technology of
enrichment has actually been working on
some third-generation centrifuges which
we've seen in R&D form but not in
operation and was building a covert
facility at home until that was outed by
President Obama and Sarkozy and
and Brownback last september-october so
Iran has been subject to how many rounds
of UN Security Council resolutions that
demanded that enrichment and the taunts
cease for to sanctions on how many
occasions five and what impact is this
hat on the trend line of their mastery
of technology for enrichment and their
accumulation of low-enriched uranium and
indeed now the processing of some mint
some further enrichment the medium in
which you ready he answers very little
very low indian pakistan another trend
line undermining the order has been the
increased numbers and roles of nuclear
weapons in the arsenals of some of the
new nuclear weapon states in particular
india and pakistan so if you remember
back in 1998 they both came out of the
basement with tests since 2001 the
pakistani nuclear arsenal has
approximately tripled proximately
tripled both India and Pakistan or on
rapid buildup of Arsenal's currently and
in both countries but especially
Pakistan nuclear weapons are part of the
active Arsenal and plans for strategy
and defense so i notice i think when i
was on the plane coming that y'all are
going to read uh is article by ripping
near on he's got a very good account of
Pakistan's development of a concept that
they call a symmetric deterrence we're
behind a nuclear shield
that is the threat to engage in a
nuclear war they think they can conduct
operations like the operation at Mumbai
so here's the the lineup a state that's
fighting to insurgencies the Taliban
Afghan and the Taliban pack where Al
Qaeda's leadership has moved in done
governed territories where the
connections between Pakistani security
services and terrorist groups or groups
that have terrorists components like LED
is quite thick and where then we see if
you remember back in 2008 at the taj
hotel in mumbai le t operatives
conducting an attack in india at the
hotel that ended up killing almost 200
people behind a shield of nuclear
weapons india has so far been deterred
but the indian military regards this as
an unacceptable set of circumstances and
if you try to think about it I was in
india in january talking to their
national security adviser i said i can't
imagine how y'all or is reserved as you
are if a mexican related terrorist group
came to the Waldorf and killed 200
people what would the u.s. do so I would
say if there's a nuclear war between two
states in the next decade it's pretty
clear who the candidates are and I'd say
the situation is extremely volatile
al-qaeda I don't need to remind you in
New York about 911 but the proposition
that al-qaeda is not seriously seeking
nuclear weapons is a proposition that
the evidence absolutely refuse
absolutely refuse and if you want the
most compelling account of that one of
the people shown in the movie was wroth
mowat Larson he was the US government's
best intelligence agent working on this
problem for the last decade he's now
come to the Belford Center at Harvard
when he retired and he's produced a
chronology of Al Qaeda's search for
nuclear bombs an unclassified chronology
you can get it at the bell for website
this belford org Belford Center down or
get the Kennedy School so they've
clearly made three buys in which they
got cheated they've clearly bought some
stuff at a point when Osama had got
frustrated by the fact that they were
not succeeding he got two key scientists
from a coup cons Pakistani establishment
that come visit him in Afghanistan this
is when he's still there and this design
of a bomb is from one of these a fellow
who actually was that that may look like
a cartoon that's not a bad design not a
bad design for a version of a gun-type
bomb so I put over here on the right
dragonfires bomb
and I'll say a word about that maybe
just in a minute so how to think about
the the risks here one thing is to work
the analytics yourself so I would say do
that the other thing is to say what do
the people who shouldered responsibility
for a problem and had access to evidence
that you and I wouldn't have on an
unclassified basis what did they
conclude so as bob gates our secretary
defense says everybody you know has
their nightmares from time to time but
when he wakes up in the middle of the
night the one that he's worried about is
terrace with a nuclear bomb george tenet
who became very seized of this issue
after nine eleven offers the view which
is a consensus view at the CIA which is
nuclear weapons is where al-qaeda
desperately wants to go and jim jones
same here's dragonfires bomb here in New
York dragonfire that story I tell in the
introduction to the nuclear terrorism
book dragonfires a source of the Sun was
a source for us intelligence who was
reporting a month after nine eleven that
al-qaeda had got a small nuclear bomb
out of the former Soviet arsenal and now
had it in New York City about to explode
as I tell in the book that was then a
bit of breathtaking and interrogatory
between bush and tenant who was in
director of CIA first did the former
Soviet arsenal include bombs of the
description that dragon fire had given
answer yes second were all these bombs
adequately accounted for answering no
could al-qaeda have got one of these
bombs and brought it to New York City
and be about to explode it and we not
otherwise know anything about it answer
so the bottom line from this
interrogatory was no basis for
dismissing dragonfires report that there
was now a live bomb in New York City
about to explode when this basis Bush
ordered Cheney to leave Washington
because if there was a bomb in New York
they might as well be one in Washington
if you remember after 911 for many
months Cheney was often said to be
missing or often his cave or otherwise
actually he was part of the continuity
of government program that we had during
the Cold War several thousand people
from the US government different
agencies also moved out of Washington to
this alternative site in the case that a
bomb went off in Washington we still
want to survive as a society we still
want to have a government this teams who
are the nuclear experts were sent to New
York to look for evidence at the bomb to
try to find it it turned out to be a
false alarm so that's the good news but
the bad news is this could have been
happening and if it had happened I
imagine that this nuclear bomb the bomb
had been smaller than this podium so a
tactical nuclear weapon quite small put
it in the back of an SUV driving into
Times Square blow it up on a work day
everything in the red zone disappears
instantaneously just vanishes consumed
by this ball of fire that's released and
this release of energy and everything
out to the blue zone you can see goes to
the to the tunnels and the bridges looks
like the federal office building in
oklahoma city after a homegrown American
that responded back in in 1996 so half
million people could die instantaneously
or in the first hour and another few
hundred thousand in the in the day in
the week that followed from radiation
poisoning and otherwise want war won't
best judgments with respect to how
serious this issue is here's a few more
and that's what's ever likely so to
conclude could the global luckily order
be as fragile as a financial order in my
view yes why not because people are not
working harder to try to make it more
secure but because trim lines powerful
trend lines are running in the opposite
direction so in a sense we have to run
faster to stay in place it's like you
were running trying to run up with a
escalator that's going down and what are
these trend lines as I say I give you
more in a systematic fashion 10 of them
in the Foreign Affairs space but they
include a North Korea that's divided the
regime in Iran that proceeds in spite of
UN Security Council resolutions and
India Pakistan dynamic that both is
increasing substantially their amount of
nuclear weapons and materials and also
in a standoff that's volatile and then
the surround which is the risk that if
and as North Korea becomes a nuclear
weapons state and if it as he ran
becomes a nuclear weapon state you'll
get a knock-on effect that will produce
a further spread of nuclear weapons and
all the while we've got al Qaeda as one
example which has been seriously seeking
nuclear weapons or the material from
which they can make up on and if they
were to succeed today the first thing we
might know about is when it occurred so
with that at the end of the of the
picture for al Qaeda in if you try to
study them as either tried it in if
we're there mo is devastating deadly and
theatrical there's a mushroom cloud in
developing a city and even though right
I don't want to make you you know light
of the fact that we're in New York i
would say in al Qaeda's mo they pick
their targets and go back after them so
among Americans who these i would say
Washington in New York in or are at the
top of their list so maybe that's enough
to say here that's the bad news the good
news let me just say one final thing in
the nuclear terrorism book the subtitle
is called the ultimate preventable
catastrophe so underlying preventable
and there I try to outline an agenda of
action and a strategy that if
undertaking if undertaken would
successfully reduce the likelihood of a
nuclear terrorist attack to nearly zero
some of those actions were not taking
some we're not taking fast enough and
we're working against very powerful
trend lines but maybe I'll talk about
that in the questions and answers if
people are interested so I'm happy to go
off in any or all directions
so I would ask those who'd like to pose
questions to come up to the microphone
in the middle of the room Chris thank
you for the presentation professor I my
name's Christopher brownfield I'm a
participant in the hurt I global
strategy initiative and I noticed here
that on this sheet that same nuclear
terrorism the ultimate venable
catastrophe you have no nuclear no new
nuclear weapon States basically to draw
a line in the sand with the eight
existing nuclear powers the problem that
I see with that is that some of these
powers India Pakistan and Israel are not
legitimized within our current regime
complex for non-proliferation and
controlled nuclear materials what ways
do you see for us to for the world to
provide some sort of legitimacy for
these powers and bring them into the
fold so that we're participating and
collaborating with them as legitimate
partners on the same level it's a very
good question let me first clarify and
then I'll try to get to the point to the
question the proposition about no new
nuclear weapon States is not to
legitimize and grandfather the current
States forever actually I think they
debate about the embrace of the vision
of a world free of nuclear weapons the
proposition that's been put by the four
horsemen and it's been endorsed by
President Obama is a very interesting
debate and I would wish and pray for a
world in which there were no nuclear
weapons I would say that's a proprietary
you know I have a extremely difficult
time figuring out how given where we are
we get from here to there but so it's
not to legitimize these others forever
it's to stop further bleeding and then
we go back and work on the other
problems or or at least first things
first but with respect to your specific
question of India Pakistan Israel who
are not nuclear weapon states in the
non-proliferation treaty where is you
problem sure studied there were five
halves that were agreed to be a
able to continue having for a while even
though article 6 commits them to
negotiate in good faith towards the
ultimate elimination of these Arsenal's
so I could one imagine amending the NPT
to allow these three in and say well
then we're really going to shut the door
no more given the fact that it's a
consensus group the answer is no if you
if you're solved the NPT review
conference here in in new york in may I
mean it's hard enough to get any
agreement in anything and so you
certainly wouldn't get a agreeable in
anything that would be hard or difficult
so what are other alternatives one that
I'm attracted to and that I've advocated
would be to create in addition to the
NPT as the the nuclear order or regime
is not only the NPT that's the
centerpiece but there's the Nuclear
Suppliers group and this trailer group
and there's the proliferation Security
Initiative there's a lot of surround
okay I would like for there to be a what
I've called a global alliance against
nuclear terrorism that I would feature
as an alliance I think the founding
members should be the US and Russia as
the states that have the largest
Arsenal's but it should be open to all
states will commit to the mission would
be doing everything feasible on the
fastest possible time table to reduce to
the lowest level the risk of nuclear
terrorism and the elements of that would
then include I've got a forgiving others
four or five elements but the crux of it
would be first a principle of nuclear
security in which all nuclear weapons
and all nuclear materials would be
secured to a gold standard that is as
good as gold in Fort Knox and would be
done in a manner sufficiently
transparent that one state could believe
that the other state had done it so
that's the principle of assured nuclear
security and then the second principle
would be nuclear accountability
in which if you made it you're going to
be held accountable in a strict
liability sense for what happens to it
so if God forbid a nuclear weapon or
material nuclear weapon usable material
is stolen by an inside crook and sold to
a terrorist and used if you made the
bomb you're responsible for the mom and
then figuring out exactly what means
responsible and accountable that's
another part of the you know burn but
it's good question and I think that the
fact that these three states are left
hanging out there in some sense is a
problem for the regime I am James
Hamilton from King's College I think you
just answer the last part of my question
but my first first part is do you see
the current nuclear security instruments
as ineffective entirely or other some
elements that you keep in your global
alliance as well I do not see them as I
mean I do not think we should be about
joking anything that we have in fact if
he said how has the NPT worked again lib
just a short history I don't know how
much all have done this already in the
course but the when they hear when
Kennedy was president he made his famous
forecast this is 1962 1963 that under
current trend lines by the end of 1970s
there'd be 25 nuclear weapon States and
nobody said that's an exaggeration you
go back to look at the coverage of it
now why because it was assumed that the
States acquired the technical capability
to build bombs they would do so just
like the other guys did in fact this is
another one of the questions down here
how many states actually started down
that road and then after the NPT stopped
and reversed course the answer is 13 at
least so Sweden had a serious nuclear
weapons from Italy had a serious nuclear
weapons
South Korea had a serious nuclear
weapons program brazil had a serious
nuclear weapons program so a huge number
of states were going down there reversed
so that with respect to the NPT I would
say a treaty that got you a hundred and
eighty-four don't mess with it okay
guess it's unraveling but don't so I
wouldn't I wouldn't try that I wouldn't
I don't think i would jettison any part
of the system while i'm working on you
know trying to restructure it but maybe
i didn't get them well i think in terms
of preventing nuclear terrorism if if if
God forbid Iran becomes a nuclear
weapons state and now you see a rush
among other countries and i would say
saudi looks at the top of the list as a
buyer not a maker and egypt is certainly
interested but who challenged turkey
will be an interesting case syria
already looking previously so if you're
building do have people building or
trying to build their own Arsenal's in
which of uranium is is happening in Iran
today or is happening in in Pakistan
you're producing more material that
material is available be stolen by
somebody and to be transferred you've
got more potential AQ Khan so stopping
the proliferation piece of this is I
think a significant part of stopping for
stopping nuclear terrorism down down the
path so i would i would keep all of the
elements but i think it needs a lot more
and if you ask if you go back to the
Nuclear Security Summit that President
Obama had in April this was a most
extraordinary event again I don't know
if y'all have dealt with it but this was
the largest gathering of heads of state
at the invitation of an American
president since FDR invited people to
San Francisco for what created the UN so
this was a big deal 42
extensive state and out of it came a
verbal commitment to lock down all
nuclear weapons and materials everywhere
as good as gold within four years that's
the good news okay that there's a
declaratory commitment the bad news is
there was no operational definition of
what means you in 1540 and as good as
gold they couldn't get agreement on that
and there was no agreement on what would
constitute appropriate transparency so
that you would have some reason to
believe that I did it other than that I
told you so I think this up a good start
but a huge amount of to be done you for
speaking to us today my name is jamayne
and I'm from Georgetown University um my
question is on a lot of effort is being
focused on nuclear non-proliferation in
counterterrorism and I'm afraid it's at
the expense of nuclear disarmament
nuclear disarmament um what I'm thinking
is that um how you define a problem
pretty much determines how you solve
that problem in this case the way this
problem is being defined is that nuclear
weapons in the hands of the wrong people
well i think that the real problem is
the nuclear weapons themselves and not
the weapons getting into the hands of
the wrong people and so um my question
to you is that what are the obstacles so
actually sitting down and talking
seriously about these are my men rather
than non-proliferation and
counterterrorism because if you don't
have the weapons then you don't have to
worry about the weapons getting into the
wrong hands project a very good question
it see it's the year I guess the tip of
an iceberg of a raven bigger question so
the NPT this bargain commits the nuclear
weapon States to disarmament so that's
no question about this you look at the
treaty we did carefully look at that
look at the history so what was said the
deal was and this was 1968
then in the force in 1970 is I have
nuclear weapons you agree not to have
nuclear weapons but I agree that nuclear
weapons are not good for me either and I
agree to enter into serious negotiations
towards the ultimate elimination so
that's the theory of the case now then
you have the Cold War so at the peak of
the Cold War how many how many nuclear
warheads were there in the world 68,000
how grotesque is that you want to get
you want to affect you if you're doing
your history part you want to kind of a
good good bookmark go back and look at
Herman cons book one thermonuclear war
which was a was taken to be a very
hawkish book he says if anybody ever had
a thousand weapons that would be insane
they say that might actually threaten to
kill everybody and citizens if they
understood it wouldn't allow that okay
so in any case we had 68,000 now since
1991 the end of the Cold War actually
both the US and the Russian arsenal have
been on a very sharp down down slump so
now it's about 2,300 approximate we
start 23,000 but in the New START treaty
the agreement is to get down to fifteen
hundred and fifty are active nuclear
arsenal clear weapons on both sides so
you're moving certainly in the right
direction not as fast as you would like
her as I would like and not as much as
we should but any case moving in the
right direction now what then are the
long-term obstacles here well I would
say there are three big big problems as
you try to think about the vision of
zero so one obstacle is I can't dis
invent nuclear weapons so if we took all
the nuclear weapons in the world today
and eliminate them what about if
somebody this builds them over again so
I need some situation to make it you
believe that i'm not doing in the closet
you know building our soul over that's
number one number two what about
cheating why don't I just save a few
nuclear weapons on the side just in case
for a rainy day so the level of an
intrusive inspection that you would need
to believe that there were not a hundred
nuclear weapons squirreled away
somewhere in the US or in Russia would
be difficult not impossible so we're
just understanding that the challenges
and then uh maybe that's enough to do to
see why it's hard that doesn't mean that
it's needs to be given up and I think in
the dynamic the non-nuclear weapon
States and so if you had been at the NPT
review conference you would have heard
this over and over and over people say
hey we made a deal we would not get
nuclear weapons and you would negotiate
seriously about eliminating your weapons
and we've still not having any weapons
and what are you doing so that that
dynamic I don't think it's a frequent
for for some of the non-proliferation
pros it's more of a rhetorical excuse
but I think in fact in the dynamic on V
legitimizing nuclear weapons for
everybody is a good part of the process
of having an impact on other states
deciding they don't want to build
nuclear weapons my colleague that's odd
hi I'm a sinner boss I got whole car
doesn't share in Pakistan studies at
Sipan South Asian shoot and I am proud
to be associated at Bell presenter my
question I have two part question one is
if you can see something more about all
what this means for US policy towards
Afghanistan Pakistan and India because
as you very rightly pointed out that all
these things are centered within
Pakistan Afghanistan in many ways what
that implies for US policy whether more
engagement with Pakistan or more
engagement with military more engagement
in bringing Pakistan and India together
a longer-term perspective perspective
about Afghanistan or not what do you say
about that an airlink
link question is that in terms of the
preventable aspects of your theory how
do you rate the performance of this
present administration thank you okay
this is these are two different
questions you as you say and so Hassan
I'm say that you guys at Columbia have
got a good good fortune and having him
here as a colleague a son when he was a
pakistani policeman was a key person in
tracking down the AQ Khan story inside
Pakistan so he's a big part of the
source of information about the way this
whole all manner unraveled I think your
first question on Afghanistan Pakistan
and India were just right and I i think
that when a president obama did this
review of our policy towards afghanistan
in you know the period from january to
april and then made his announcement at
west point of an additional thirty
thousand troops for afghanistan
basically what we did was take a you
know take a magnifying glass and look at
Afghanistan now of course you have to
look at Afghanistan because there's
already before the thirty thousand
seventy thousand Americans fighting
there and it was the place where I okay
that was when the attack occurred so
there was no way you're not going to
look at it but we looked at it and or
not it seems to me that the review
process looked at it and if you asked
about the region you would say what
vital interests and right thinking does
the u.s. have in Afghanistan or to put
it another way suppose al-qaeda hadn't
been in Afghanistan they've been in
Sudan where they were before until they
got kicked out when the attack on nine
eleven occurred is there any would we be
saying oh hundred thousand troops and a
hundred billion dollars a year for
Afghanistan is the solution no I would
say that we would
Afghanistan would look like Somalia or
Yemen or many other horrible situations
in the world but not ones that we think
the solution to is a hundred thousand
American troops than 100 billion dollars
a year for a long-term project so I
think that by focusing on the problem
that was the urgent we might not have
taken enough account of the important so
if I were looking at the region I would
like my magnifying glass would start
with Pakistan why well you know better
than I did Pakistan is this cauldron in
some sense so it's a country severely
challenged as I mentioned before by two
serious insurgencies al-qaeda
headquarters so terrorists are a
confrontation with a much larger almost
whatever seven eight times larger
adversary with room it's fought three
wars and almost another two with a
fragile political system I mean this is
a comp this is a problem and back to our
q and A's here in the Commission on
preventing or so they this congressional
convention commission i mentioned on
preventing WMD proliferation and
terrorism it says quote if you map
terrorism and weapons of mass
destruction all roads intersect in
pakistan so i would say they're huge
vital national interest in pakistan so I
would look first at pakistan and if i
say my next question well what nation
has the biggest impact on pakistan you
know a lot better than i do but i don't
think it's Afghanistan I don't think
it's things emanating from Afghanistan I
think it's India well but we have an
emissary who looks at
Afghanistan Cobra and at pakistan they
can look that but he's not allowed to
say the word india other than to say i
don't know anything about india india is
not my problem india is not my perfume
india doesn't really have all that much
impact on pakistan I mean I had him up
and okay yeah in Harvard for a form of
it this spring and he said I'm obliged
to say India has no impact on Pakistan I
said how could he say this he said i'm
obliged to say this is ok so that's what
he says is not true ok so how them to
think about india and pakistan
interaction again extremely difficult
and you know better than I do but if you
have countries that have fought three
wars have come to the edge of a couple
of additional wars have a territorial
dispute that seems vital to each of them
this is a is the powder keg and it could
many different things could could could
could could set it off so the idea that
then both of these countries are rapidly
expanding their stockpile of nuclear
weapons usable material which India is
doing in part as a result of the US
Indian agreement makes no sense to me
and the fact that Pakistan is expanding
its arsenal of material makes makes no
sense to me oh I would say that's a you
put your finger on a on a tough tough
set of problem and that is not I'm
describing the problems more than the
solutions because i think the solutions
are you know a little bit here and a
little bit there i don't know of any
grand solution to the to the issue on
obama and the obama administration i
would say for for identifying the issue
of nuclear danger including nuclear
terrorism and nuclear proliferation i
would give obama an a if you imagine a
president that comes to office in
january of 09 in the midst of a
financial crisis that's just about to
become a great depression
and he says I can think of something
even worse know who would do this okay I
mean only a strange character so i would
say wonderful to have a president that
has his head around the subject is his
coordinates with respect to the issue
seemed to me to be right again if you
take it when he came here in September
for the UN General Assembly get a parade
of of heads of state it just happened by
accident that the u.s. was chair of the
security of the Security Council so he
said I'll I'll chair the Security
Council because I'm going to be there
that day and then the chair gets to set
the agenda so he said we were talking
about nuclear terrorism he said what you
don't know there's a financial crisis
there you know what's about financial
crisis and there's going to be
Copenhagen with climate disruption we
should talk about that he said I'm the
chairman and we were talking about
nuclear terrorism so that was the
subject for the for his session and this
Nuclear Security Summit i already
mentioned so i would say for for
identifying the problems and trying to
work on him high marks where i would say
there's a big question mark and a big
question mark is in the mounting of a
strategy and operational plan that leads
to the actions that would be required to
bend these trend lines and you mentioned
india and pakistan that's one extremely
good example but i would say if you look
at North Korea it's about to say here in
about the same you know in terms of the
trend line so these trend lines haven't
been yet and I would say that the
strategy and plan of action for bending
them if I've just looking at in the
record at this point it's not not yet
been successful thank you so much it's a
great pleasure to associate a face with
all the reading I've done viewers for
the past 30 years oh I attended a
conference at Stanford in 98 99 that
Holloway organised specifically on the
question of proliferation how do you
deactivate the nuclear arsenal of the
former Soviet Union and an image that
still sticks in my mind is sort of like
of a farmhouse in rural Pennsylvania
that was the shot in Murmansk where they
restored nuclear weapons and the whole
object there was well what's going on
and even at that conference people from
the military from DIA we're talking
about that there were weapons already
missing which was quite disturbing to
listen to so my question is in the
sheets you give you talk about all these
incidents that have happened in recent
years where we act on the issue of
securing these weapons and secondly when
you think of the cassis Bell I for the
war in Iraq certainly the issue of WMD
was thrown in our face thrown in the
world's face and as we know the outcome
of that is questionable to say the least
so how can we review these conflicts or
possible use of pre-emptive military
force with that kind of background to
the public being dubious of claims of
WMD being put forth as a rationale to go
to war whoa two wonderful questions and
huge questions so let me just skim the
surface on on both of them as we said in
the introduction I've been extremely
interested in this question for a long
time ranking and wind afternoon Luger
which was in the end of 91 then when
Clinton was elected I became secretary
sistent Secretary of Defense and my
colleague ash awesome and we had just
written a book called cooperative
denuclearization so we came with a
little game plan and had the opportunity
to try to help put some of these things
into in the motion in 1991 December dick
cheney was on Meet the Press this is
good to remember you can look it up
punch
he was secretary defense for Papa bush
and he's asked that I this is an
epigraph for the chapter where in
nuclear terrorism he's asked if the if
the Soviet Union should disappear or
should collapse what's going to happen
to this 22 these nuclear weapons but
could some of them come loose and he
says and it's quote he says well let's
say they have 25,000 weapons if they're
99% of factor then they'll only be 250
weapons you know loose and he says and
with the chaos you know would be with
the collapse of a state fed ex would
have a trouble with doing better than
that now where are those 250 weapons
I've searched for him every day ho
monster hey and if tomorrow we find one
I wouldn't be shocked so one of the most
amazing things to me about the last
almost 19 years is not one single
nuclear weapon from the former Soviet
arsenal has been found loose out not one
material yes but a bomb of actual
nuclear weapon how to account for that I
would say first most important extreme
professionalism by the former Soviets
and Russians especially in the 12th guma
I mean that's extra human your country
collapses there's total corruption
everywhere is chaos and you don't pick
up a few weapons and become rich but I
would i give this presentation to
Russians I say thank God the 12th goomba
was not consistent of investment bankers
we were taught to monetize their SS so
in any case the big none Luger and the
u.s. cooperation has been a big piece of
it but then is a huge portion of
disgrace or good fortune or good luck
okay for so far so I wouldn't take any
of that for granted but any case the
fact that some that a strategy was
developed some things were done I think
the result
that this stage is the level of security
of nuclear weapons and materials in
Russia is hugely better that it was in
1991 though the 12th guma was probably
more professional in 1991 than it is
today because Russians become even more
corrupt Society unfortunately so I'd
bring on the Russian piece on other
other countries i would say Pakistan
complicated story particularly as the
material expands India as the material
expands complicated story South Africa
is a good case that if you look at pill
and a bone there's dirty bombs worth of
material South Africa is the only
country that build nuclear weapons
itself and then eliminated himself but
the material for those weapons about 30
bombs worth of stuff is still kept at a
place in fill in da bomb where if you
look at if you can YouTube it or
something on 60 minutes did a very good
program one the fact that two
independent to two groups of more than
four armed people penetrated pedal and
Davao simultaneously shot a guard stole
some stuff this is back in two thousand
and whatever eight so there's a lot of
places that are still not not not well
secured and Obama's objective of all
weapons all materials to go standard in
four years is a good it seems to be a
good objective but very ambitious very
ambitious when your second question it's
certainly right that among that terrible
tragedies of Iraq as far as I'm
concerned was that was kind of the
opportunity cost that basically we
played the card of a rocky WMD including
even a while and i would say wild
statements about a nuclear program in
iraq when that was not the view of the
intelligence community that was not the
view of the IAEA chemical and biological
weapons
yes that was thought to be in a row but
no clear no no any case turn out that
having gone to war on a false premise
going down to the next party and say you
know shrink Cara look at this problem it
was with somewhat less credibility so
your point is exactly correct and I
think it's something that we've had to
labor labor against um we'll probably
have to wrap up right around seven
thirty so the last people standing are
going to be the last one status
questions tonight over you Nick hi my
name is Nick Standish I'm an
undergraduate at here Columbia and a
participant in the hertog global
strategy initiative my question regards
like government agencies such as the
nuclear emergency search team it seems
as if the what is publicized in terms of
successes or in terms exercises the
public for very good reasons doesn't
seem to see what protocols are in place
and what sort of sensors we have at our
borders and all these sorts of things
and I wonder if you could comment on the
sort of dangers of maybe the unknowing
for the American public in terms of what
is already being done to combat nuclear
terrorism and because in your
presentation you have the quotes of
senior officials and you commented
saying that they are privy to all of
these sorts of declassified information
and if they're worried then we should
also I wonder if you could sort of talk
about good good points so trying as a
citizen on the basis of unclassified
information to come to conclusions is
complicated it's a very good point and
there's absolutely no question that
thousands of people working for the US
government get up and work very hard
every day trying to reduce nuclear
danger and that they've been doing this
for a long long time and especially
since 1991 with gun Luger so there's a
big Cooperative Threat Reduction program
at Homeland Security there's a BIM know
the whatever
you know a unit that tries to build up
Homeland Security capability against
nuclear lots of people working extremely
hard the best way I think to try to do
the net of it done is to see there's to
ask what do the people who actually do
have all this information what are they
regard as the bottom lines and I think
it just as I said the bottom lines look
worrisome very worrisome because even
though we're running harder and working
harder if you're going the wrong way on
an escalator that that's how it works
and the escalator may be speeding up so
we can work very hard but I think North
Koreans working pretty hard to or we can
work very hard but al Qaeda is working
pretty good so we're working against
intelligent determine adversaries as
well as against technology where the
diffusion of knowledge is unstoppable
and the advance of Technology is
unstoppable most of that has a positive
spin to it but it also has an underbelly
so it's a good it's a good question and
I'd say that looking at the judgments is
probably the best best bottom line
you for your presentation you have been
talking about these different programs
of you speak a little louder or closer
elimination and then but at the same
time you have put this example of anyone
who could like hype weapons of mass
destruction or even try to produce so I
wanted to I was thinking about a
combination of these kind of programs
and strategies but at the same time
maybe the necessity to to combine with
other measures we should try to promote
democracy or another kind of processes
in order to consolidate Maurice table
regimes and to try to make these people
it's the thing that we are like enemies
or like so I wanted to listen to your
view about these Oh their solution sorry
no not going on it's a big a big
question so i won't do justice since i
haven't done justice to the other
questions i'm certainly not that this
one in their international relations as
you've learnt in your course consists of
at least for the last however long
thousands of years conflicts between
states with conflicting interests often
with conflicting views of situations
often with stereotypes often with
mistakes often with confusion the
motivations that would lead a guy like
shahzad this fellow who was the times
square bomber living in Connecticut to
think he's going to take SUV Phillip
pull up some stuff going The Times
Square and ball it up I don't know what
I would say it's going to be a long time
before all of those problems are erased
indeed if I take it closer to home the
oklahoma city bomber was an American
veteran wasn't particularly poor was
living in Oklahoma City was just pissed
at whatever the world and he fills his
truck with with bombs and kills 100
I can't remember 170 you know children
and this so some percentage of people
are going to be fairly strange i would
say for a long time so i believe in the
nuclear terrorism space we need
therefore to focus on the means more
than the motive so if we can deny a
terrorist's the means to achieve their
deadliest aspirations even if in their
head they would like to kill 4 million
people well they can so maybe they'll
kill for or maybe they'll kill 40 now
that's not a very good but it's not the
whole solution to the problem over time
when hope said in normal societies
people have more opportunities and fewer
of them they're crazy or a few of them
are crazy enough to what they kill you
know somebody else so I'd say that's the
long-term aspiration but the evolution
of international relations to the point
where people are not threatening and
actually using force against other
people i think is a is a long long
agenda but the agenda of preventing
nuclear terrorism i think is a is it is
an immediate agenda so maybe with that
one I could I say stuff thank you so
much Graham Allison